hey leute hier ist wieder eure wann sie
als ich wollte nur sagen dass ich jetzt
doch kein vermerk bin und ich will die
augen geöffnet haben spaß
ich weiß viele sind jetzt sehr
enttäuscht weil sie auf dieses video
gewartet haben wo ich die klarstellung
mache und es ist eine klarstellung
irgendwo aber eine andere nicht sitzt
heute auf meinem sofa ich es ich komme
sogar nach hinten lehnen es sonst nur
davor
ich dachte mal ein bisschen abwechslung
warum macht dass man diesen helfen was
ist das alles mache ich immer so wie
jetzt mal ganz ernst und nur vanessa
keine rolle
als ich das video hochgeladen habe habe
ich schon mit gegenwind gerechnet aber
was dann kam war echt ja erstmal haben
ganz viele diese anspielung nicht
verstanden und dann kam so eine welle
von empörung auf mich zu alter falter
zunächst gab es die bienchen die mich
abonniert hatten und ganz schön
enttäuscht von mir waren und dann gab es
noch solche kommentare wo ich dachte da
bin ich wirklich so eine gute
schauspielerin
ich dachte eigentlich nicht erfahrung
mir wirklich leid abgekauft im internet
darfst du nicht gelten denn du willst
nur angelogen und mir wurde vorgeworfen
dass ich ein hater bin was ich natürlich
verstehen kann weil das natürlich auch
so rüberkommen kann aber spätestens nach
diesem kommentar hier ist ja wohl allen
klar dass das kein held war ja und wenn
gerade ein thema im mittelpunkt steht
oder so ein krasser tief irgendwie am
gange ist dann springe ich auch mal
gerne auf den zug auf weil mir das spaß
macht ich reagiere auf solche sachen mal
gerne mit humor und das haben viele
überhaupt nicht verstanden was auch
alles okay ist denn wir sind da
individuelle menschen und ich will mich
rechtfertigen ich will es nur erklären
weil viele wirklich nicht dass tokio
hotel an die video kennen und dazu muss
sagen habt ihr was großes verpasst und
deshalb verlange ich euch das video
nochmal hier damit ihre tokio hotel
angie kennt denn das ist youtube von
anfang an so war youtube mal
obwohl ich glaube dass mein video und es
gibt menschen da draußen die denken dass
sich die böse du meine vanessa bin die
alle nur fertig machen will
und das stimmt gar nicht ich bin super
süß und dieser ruf jetzt geklaut aber
das ist mir egal
und jetzt lasst uns alle ganz doll lieb
haben
denn eines weiß ich ganz sicher auch
wenn es diese ahnungslosen und super
gemeinen menschen da draußen gibt habe
ich doch echt ne geile community was
habe ich euch gefeiert und so viele
kannten die anspielungen so viele
verstehen auch was ich mit meinen videos
immer so sagen möchte und wie das
gemeint ist ich meine wir sind 63.000
leute hier
danke dass ihr meinen komischen humor
feiert und es da draußen leute gibt die
genau denselben komischen humor haben
denn das ist doch das schönste und an
alle leute die mich nicht mögen ist okay
wir werden uns im realen leben
wahrscheinlich eh nie sehen also alles
gut wir haben uns alle lieb
gerade